you know honestly i wish people would
just ask me hey steven is
this a good idea i'm about to sell out
my entire brand
for a few thousand dollars maybe even a
few million dollars is this a good idea
and i would tell them uh no terrible
idea
such is the case with kevin o'leary who
has become a national embarrassment
recently
and let me also say i understand that
becoming a national embarrassment is
hard to do like
most of us we could never be national
embarrassment at best i'm a local
embarrassment to my mother the friends
who know me
it's hard to be a national embarrassment
you already have to be nationally
known and so most people we don't even
qualify but kevin o'leary definitely
is in the running because he's already a
massive star
thanks to shark tank you guys know the
show right it's like the wwe of venture
capitalism
people hate this product i hate it too
you know investor comes on pours out his
life's work
and this is a bad idea they're always
like yeah i want like
a hundred percent of your equity for
five thousand dollars here's my offer
for
100 of rock block
[Music]
and that's the show and it's fine it's
hilarious but one of the things that
annoys me is the way that
these sharks have been selling out their
reputations
maybe because they're not getting paid
enough maybe they need a bigger yacht
maybe they need a bigger house i don't
know what it is
but now that they're all massive
celebrities they've been selling out
their image
and moving totally away from this idea
that they had when they were sharks like
oh we're no-nonsense business guys
into selling out their brand to the
highest bidder no matter how scrupulous
or
unscrupulous they were we already
covered robert herchevac
who was caught in a little real estate
scheme but you should also know
other sharks are also doing this damon
john
uh also endorsed jason bond picks which
if you guys know stocks you know what a
joke that guy is
all right listen before i contacted
jason i'm a shark right you know i have
no problem about you know ripping
somebody apart or just saying i'm out
no you're a sellout for money you know
instead of having to go to the office
every day and talking to full staff or
worrying about who buys this shirt or
what new company i invest in
i'm gonna be sitting on my yacht trading
well guys it's that easy just
forget about a business trade from your
yacht so that's a massive
l right there but nothing is worse at
all
pales in comparison to what i'm about to
show you guys today because kevin
o'leary has taken
sell out to the extreme and gotten
himself
on cameo now guys if you don't know what
cameo is it's like a place where you can
get birthday shout outs from the boy
band from the 90s that you used to like
and your friend still likes them so you
get them best wishes for a birthday or
whatever on cameo for like 90 bucks
okay that's what you're supposed to do
on cameo if you have an ounce left of
self-respect
what kevin o'leary is doing on cameo is
charging twelve hundred dollars
for business shout outs for any business
that you want
hey everybody mr wonderful here hey mr
wonderful here hey mr wonderful from
shark tank here
busy kid and that's what training was
all about millcroft lawn care
pronosa it's a website that personalizes
and helps you grow your business
it's the only app where your kids can
track their chores
you know look please call anthony or
visit his website
www.burlingtonlawncare.com
now if you're a plastic surgeon you're
going to want to hear me on this thing
i'm shouting out for a service called
plastic surgeon
ad experts it's been you know like what
you're shouting out for plastic surgeon
at who
uh kevin what do you know about these
guys
besides the script they gave you to read
you have to generate leads you want to
do that efficiently
productively and you want your customer
acquisition cost
to be as efficient as possible and
that's exactly
exactly what surgeon ad experts do so
check out
plastic surgeon ad experts
because they're focused on your vertical
if you're a plastic surgeon
check it out i mean am i crazy here this
is
this is embarrassing like he doesn't
even disclose the fact that he's
being paid to do this right like if i
have if i'm shouting out
i don't know blue moon to use a
offhand example i have to tell you i'm
sponsored by blue moon i'm not gonna say
hey i'm doing a shout out for my friends
over at blue moon
uh they're not my friends they're paying
me to say this and
look it goes on and on hey mr wonderful
here
and one of the things that everybody's
thinking about is can i get a side
hustle
who are you shouting out now come on
kevin tell us who
i'm doing one for side hustle app
oh great side hustle app paid him to do
this and why
would he do this right why why would
people pay so much money for this
because 1200
is a lot if you're just gonna keep this
cameo to yourself because that's what
cameos are meant to do but that's not
how people are using kevin o'leary's
shout outs and he knows that they use
them to endorse their own business
look at this e trio gets a shout out
from mr wonderful
shark tanks most beloved kevin o'leary
gives a big shout out to satha
yelanamachili okay check it out
hi mr wonderful here and i love to
celebrate entrepreneurship
and i mean globally so here's a really
interesting shout out
hey buddy you're not doing a shout out
you are doing thousands of sponsorship
posts and selling out your brand to
trick
consumers let's be clear about what
you're doing it's not a you like how he
does that like
uh oh it's a great shout out interesting
shout out i have going on here
uh not what you're doing buddy so here's
a really interesting shout out
look at this kevin they spelled his name
wrong literally
of shark tank endorses e-trio
and look why wouldn't they say that they
paid 1200 to say that
and kevin knows they paid to say that i
can't even tell you how many people
lately i've seen do this where they get
kevin o'leary specifically
he's like the king of this of these fake
shout outs
hi mr wonderful from shark tank here has
sold nearly a thousand different
products on amazon alone
check out sophie's book thank you for
the kind
words kevin there it is you can pretend
like the endorsement was
all natural what i paid for it what do
you mean this is just what
kevin o'leary me and kevin o'leary we're
just tight like this we're just tight
like this because
he never says it's a sponsorship he just
says it's a shout out
so you can do what this lady's doing and
put it in your youtube ad oh yes
dude he has sold out the soul of this
show
and just been like hey you know it stood
for
real people making real companies forget
all that
i'll sell you i'll sell you a shout out
for 1200 are you kidding me
and look he's done he's got 157 reviews
on here
and if you think that you know on
average probably one in ten people
review a product we can actually find
out how much he's made from this whole
uh
sellout right so if uh one out of ten
people
actually reviewed it then we have uh
1500 people who actually bought it
twelve hundred dollars a pop kevin
o'leary's made
two million dollars from his quick
little sell out there
and and honestly i do get the hustle
listen what i am gonna say though
is you have to accept the responsibility
for what you do
so if you if all you want to do is shout
outs on cameo
okay but then you can't pretend to be
the the
investor that we're all supposed to take
seriously you can't be the guy
whose word we're supposed to be like oh
if he endorses that product it's a big
deal
dude this guy will endorse human poop
if it paid him 1200 and i'm not sure
that that's
an exaggeration even because kevin has
endorsed
some doozies dude check this out this is
done for you
agency launch already we see kind of
kevin over there we'll get to him in a
second
but look at this guy okay this guy's
some 25 year old nothing and look at
this picture right
look at this picture that he's got right
here now do you know anything notice
anything funny about
this picture like uh he's clearly
talking to some interviewer or something
like that here's a little entrepreneur
oh sure he's wearing air pods that's a
little bit weird right but i'm not gonna
hate on him for that
but look over
right wait sorry i can't see properly
uh right here you see something wrong
with that bookshelf
this is an entrepreneur who has
green screened himself into a fake
interview
for fake social clout this is a lie
it is a green screen set now listen am i
going to judge someone with a green
screen set
you're damn dry well dude you can't
trust someone with the green screen set
let me be the first to say it
and yet we have mr cell out here
who approves the whole thing andrew
pavia is
mr wonderful approved social media now
is an incredibly powerful force if you
know how to harness it so i'm doing a
shout out for andrew pavia
interesting entrepreneur oh
very interesting entrepreneur don't you
think kevin's probably done a lot of
research into andrew papia he's done
that due diligence he's done the due
diligence of
the done for you agency launch his
five-year plan right oh yeah very
interesting entrepreneur very
interesting
first digital lead business when he's 21
years old jim leads fast and he's become
almost a consultant to those that use
digital platform
he's almost become a consultant dude
you're reading off a teleprompter kevin
it's enough this is embarrassing stop it
stop it like at some point you have sold
out too much
right like don't pretend you know all
this guy's history
he's given you a script to read for
twelve hundred dollars
let's be clear with the consumer what
this is why should we respect these
celebrity entrepreneurs if they're gonna
turn around and sell out their image for
nothing
for 1200 bucks dude i can't imagine
listen i get that he's making tons of
money and god bless him for it
but for me it's kind of it kind of
ruined shark tank when i see
all the entrepreneurs on shark tank
selling out their brand
for nothing i don't know i want to hear
what you guys think
am i exaggerating things i i honestly do
think
kevin o'leary for this for selling out
his name this many times
that's this is national embarrassment
territory like i said i know it's a
stretch
i know it's a high bar not many people
have reached the pantheon
of national embarrassment most people
have only reached the state level
or the local level or the council the
city council level
but kevin o'leary i think in my opinion
he's gone all the way to the
tippity-tippity top
let me know what you guys think in the
comments below and just remember guys
you can't believe everything you see on
the internet and don't forget to smash
like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
comes along